of all the things i expected from eldon
ring a sense of serenity wasn't one of
them whether you've played from
software's games or simply aware of them
you likely have an idea of what they
offer doomed kingdoms tragic characters
a pervasive sense of melancholy and
gameplay that will challenge both your
skill and resolve and yet what defined
my seven hours of hands-on time with the
elden ring closed network test was what
many would consider uncharacteristic of
a soulsborne game
tranquility
as much of a surprise as that was it's
not something that's completely uncommon
in these games whether it's the nexus
filing shrine hunter's dream or the
dilapidated temple each from soft title
has a place where adventurers can find
respite from the cruelty of the world
beyond these places have a sympathetic
quality to them somehow being able to
acknowledge the harshness of the world
lament that its fate has been put upon
your shoulders and comfort you when
you're at your lowest giving you the
space to put yourself together before
you pick yourself up and venture out
once more walking around the lands
between specifically a small section of
an area called lingrave i felt that same
intent but laid out over a vast open
world the gentle understated music that
played as i wandered around aimlessly or
marveled at the beautiful golden archery
towering above invited me to let my
guard down and take in the world around
me without fear that a blade would
suddenly be plunged into me and when i
did i found the world to be both
familiar and unlike anything in from
software's previous games the lands
between is undoubtedly yet another place
ruled by figures that have been tainted
by other worldly power and corrupted but
it's also a beautiful place teeming with
life that came through strongest when i
opened the map picked a location that
interested me and attempted to reach it
along the way i stopped on the edge of
cliffs and gazed out into the horizon as
day turned to night i watched animals
like goats and penguins or whatever
their fantasy equivalents are in this
world just being for some reason i was
oddly fascinated with birds which didn't
attack me when i approached as i
expected instead they simply took flight
and landed elsewhere then there was the
sound of the wild crashing ocean waves
whispering winds rustling trees the
pitter patter of raindrops it was
hypnotic
this is all incredibly basic stuff for
an open world game perhaps even
unremarkable given the prevalence in
similar types of games but in a souls
born game these sounds are more unusual
than multi-armed monsters wielding
swords the reason it stuck with me is
because as the tarnished you're not
walking in the ashes of a fallen kingdom
or doomed city but fighting to change
the fate of a place that is very much
still alive and that is something new
for from software it's nothing short of
a miracle
that the guidance of grace can lead you
maidenless as you are to the perfect
place to die in obscurity elden ring it
seems is a game built around both
exploration and discovery the setting of
the lands between feels like a place
that is designed to constantly pique
your curiosity and then reward you for
seeking out answers in my time with the
game i found all manner of interesting
things unprompted underground crypts
that held new weapons caves so dark that
each step forward felt like a perilous
risk and yes that classic from software
moment where i ventured into the unknown
and emerged in the familiar showing that
the world was constructed thoughtfully
truth be told i'm certain that i didn't
see all of what most would call that
main events in the demo because i just
wanted to poke around in different parts
of the map this thankfully was made
incredibly easy thanks to the fast
travel system from software has
implemented from the very outset i was
able to move between sites of grace the
game's equivalent of bonfires as i
discovered them eldon ring allows you to
progress time at the sights of grace too
so i kept checking out different areas
at different times of the day to see if
anything changed they didn't hear but
they may do in the full release or i
would do so just to get a sense of how
it felt to be there as the state of the
world shifted needless to say i lost
myself in the game before i'd even
crossed swords with a challenging boss
but cross swords i did and it was pretty
much exactly what i wanted from the game
for better or worse depending on your
perspective the combat oriented gameplay
in eldon ring feels like a dark souls
game i mentioned dark souls specifically
because bloodborne and sakura shadows
die twice have distinct pacing feel and
mechanics that distinguish them elden
ring is built within the framework of
souls albeit with some changes here and
there the most noticeable of these is
the ability to jump which not only makes
hopping around for traversal
considerably easier and more reliable
but also introduces some interesting new
wrinkles to combat naturally leaping
away from danger is now a viable escape
tactic but its use in offense is likely
where most will get mileage from the
jump launching at an enemy and executing
a heavy attack will deal a crushing blow
that breaks the target's stance opening
them up for follow-ups provided you've
got the stamina to do so the other major
new addition is the guard counter which
is executed by using a heavy attack
immediately after guarding when done
properly this will also break an enemy's
stance it felt like a satisfying way to
turn defense into offense quickly but it
also requires some thought as many
enemies especially mini bosses and
bosses will have follow-up attacks of
their own and may even shrug off
incoming damage from you to deliver
those picking the right moment and
employing a solid strategy is still
important when using a guard counter
this i feel has the potential to switch
up the dynamics of combat in the same
way that counters with the gun in
bloodborne did but without the strict
execution window they demanded i spent
the majority of my time using the bloody
wolf class and by default it had a
broadsword and shield the latter of
which allowed me to execute the parry
and riposte combo interestingly
different equipment can often bestow
different abilities too using their
sword my character was able to summon a
bolt of lightning that struck targeted
enemies to deal big damage at the cost
of some of my focus point bar later i
stumbled upon a cavalcade of soldiers
protecting a carriage being dragged by
two giants throwing caution to the wind
i decided to engage initially crouching
to sneak into nearby foliage and hide
approaching when safe to backstab a
specific enemy that looked like trouble
once they were onto me i created some
distance and began picking off the
approaching soldiers with my lightning
strikes taking out any that got close by
swinging my sword the giants meanwhile
required a new strategy elden ring gives
players the ability to summon a steed
called torrent more of an extremely
capable goat than a horse and in turn
this enables mounted combat my strategy
for the giants given their massive reach
and devastating power was hit and run
which worked very effectively even if it
did take a while mounted combat felt
cumbersome at first but was able to
eventually get comfortable by adopting
different strategies depending on the
size of the enemy for larger enemies
like the giants or other mounted
opponents locking on and strafing around
them was the way to go however moving
while attempting to hit smaller on-foot
enemies proved to be very unwieldy in
most cases though i could simply stop
and use the knockback from my attacks to
keep me safe one of the smarter
additions to the souls formula in eldon
ring comes in the form of rewards for
defeating enemy mobs one-on-one combat
against enemies in the open world is
very simple and i suspect won't be a
challenge for many players so as not to
make combat in the open world trivial
from software here has also peppered in
groups of enemies which prove to be a
much greater challenge some like strange
bat-like creatures will take the
opportunity to swarm you others like
soldiers will alert nearby troops and a
skirmish against a handful of enemies
can quickly escalate into a battle
against multiple knights and even
heavily armored mounted soldiers to
ensure players are engaging these mobs
instead of just circumventing them the
game offers replenishments to your hp
and fp flask if you manage to emerge
victorious it's not always worth the
risk but i often found that i was
inclined to engage mobs knowing that i
had a good chance of regaining recovery
items over the course of the fight this
approach seems to create a good risk
versus reward consideration while also
delivering some of the edge of the seat
combat scenarios we know and love if
single enemies and mobs represent
challenge at the low and mid tier the
more classically souls level of
challenge namely hard was found in the
boss enemies i encountered these
presented the classic loop of being
mercilessly ravaged while trying to
defend myself find the right moment to
strike chip away at a boss's health and
have the good sense not to overextend
lest thou be crushed in an instant
put these foolish animations to rest
what stuck out to me most about these
fights was that from software clearly
has identified that after four souls
games their bosses often fit into
archetypes and as a result there are
effective strategies that can be relied
upon ask any soul's warm player about
how to deal with big lumbering enemies
with swords and there's a good chance
they'll say get up in their booty and
start stabbing for night like opponents
circle strafing and rolling between
their sword swings is generally a decent
starting point however i found that
these strategies were not nearly as
reliable in the fights i had in elden
ring bloodhound dary will for example
was a boss i discovered out in the wild
a strange glyph in a circular arena
transported me to what felt like a
parallel instance of that location and i
was face to face with an incredibly
aggressive enemy despite clearly being
some sort of twisted oversized human
bloodhound dairy wheel moved like a
rabid dog leaping around the arena it
was incredibly aggressive giving me very
little opportunity to create space and
when i did manage to it would swiftly
close the gap and apply pressure i
barely had time to even slip from my hp
flask so using my lightning ability was
a death sentence although the guard
counter allowed me to do some damage the
erratic nature of its attacks meant we
often traded blows and it was doing way
more damage than i could take to rely on
it rolling through attacks and landing
quick strikes was clearly the way to go
but instead i opted to stand my ground
and learn the parry timing it took a few
attempts but eventually i was able to
identify its tails and respond with a
swing of my shield to knock it back and
repulse dealing huge damage with each
onslaught of its attacks the stakes grew
higher as did the pressure but when i
finally landed that final hit the sense
of relation i felt was
well classically from software all these
years later that gameplay loop is as
intoxicating as the first time i
experienced it the other major fight of
the beta i had was against the guardian
of stormville castle who somehow was
even more aggressive despite being huge
margaret moved incredibly fast jumping
at me and swinging his massive sword in
a sweeping motion making it really
difficult to maneuver around him he was
also able to summon ethereal golden
blades that he could throw from a
distance or use as a secondary attack up
close for this fight i had to employ
spirit summons these are executed using
special items and at the cost of fp they
are also only possible in specific
locations where the rebirth monuments
are nearby i called upon a pack of
wolves that while not particularly hardy
when they met margaret's blade gave me
just enough breathing room to get a few
attacks in unchallenged and also back
away from danger to recover health again
this was a situation where my years of
playing soulsborne games created an
expectation of how this fight would go
and how i could approach it but from
software subverted that market was a
satisfying challenge and one of many i
expect
the last major piece of the soulsborne
puzzle death and rebirth has also
undergone some changes for eldon ring in
from software's dark souls games the
penalty for dying was harsh you'd
respawn at a bonfire with all your
currency lost often a considerable
distance away from where you died and be
encouraged to make the same perilous
journey all over again in order to
recover that lost currency however in an
open world this approach could become
incredibly frustrating as players have a
greater freedom of approach
to address this from software has
introduced stakes of marika which are
effectively checkpoints near a major
encounter or area of interest in the
open world if you happen upon an
encampment or a random dungeon chances
are one of the stakes of america are
located nearby there's an on-screen
indicator to confirm this upon death you
are given the choice of either reviving
at the last sight of grace you visited
or the stakes of marika in the area this
option will undoubtedly make the game
less punishing as it won't feel like you
need to go through an uphill struggle
just to get to the starting line again
and it also feels good to be able to
retry a challenge almost immediately
eldon ring is from software's first real
attempt at an open world action game and
based on what i've played so far it
feels like a smart elaboration of the
games they make best it isn't poised to
be a fundamental reinvention of its
gameplay template but it's not one that
i think is going to feel overly familiar
by pushing back the boundaries they've
created a wealth of new opportunities to
explore and the chance to
re-contextualize some older ones the
soul of from software's games the
challenging gameplay specifically is
very much present in eldon ring but from
software looks like it's creating a
stronger body around that core with this
new game there are things that i've not
stopped thinking about since playing
questions that remain unanswered the
beach i accidentally found myself on
where strange silver glyphs were being
stamped into the ground the decrepit
church that i discovered which had a
toppled over statue of a dragon with the
flame still burning in its mouth these
were just a couple of mysteries i
encountered in a very small slice of the
lands between and i had very little
context for how they fit into the
narrative underpinning the game needless
to say i cannot wait to see how it all
comes together and as a fan of from
software's previous games i hope it
lives up to my hopes few things are as
exciting to me as the idea of an open
world souls game
i offer you an accord
[Music]
you